Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 12th,
2000 and fucking 18.
I still haven't fixed this stupid
microphone. Um, how are you?
How's it going?
How's it going in your world?
I know everybody who hates the
Patriots is, is, is happy today.
Jesus Christ. What? A
bunch of babies, man.
I've never seen a fucking
team while maybe not to dupe,
I guess we used to fucking
hate the Yankees like that,
but it's just like every time we lose a
fucking game, it's like eight days. Yeah.
Other wheels coming. Oh, I
mean, how many fucking times?
One of these times it's going to be the
end. Cherub. Brady's fucking 41 years old.
All these fucking jerk offs talking shit.
And by the way,
Dion Louis out were really
disappointed with that.
Yeah.
They asked them, was it personally? He
said, is it personal? He said, hell yeah.
It's personal. That's what happens when
you go cheap. You get your ass kicked.
It's like, dude, this
isn't something new. This,
this was going on way before when you
would like fucking eight years old.
This is the way they ran the team and
you went in there and you got yourself a
ringer to, what's the problem? Jesus
Christ. Yeah, it is what happens.
Would you go cheap?
You'll lose a game in November.
These guys just acted like they just
knocked this out of the fucking playoffs.
Um,
however,
I couldn't help but think when I did
not watch one second and that game
yesterday, sorry, I was
flying back from Chicago.
I watched some highlights of it and uh,
I hadn't seen my Kiddo in
like a week. So, you know,
obviously I'm not going to come home and
sit down and watch a fucking football
game. I do have it on tape. I am
going to fucking watch it or whatever.
What have you, what? Whatever
you kids call it. I have
to, I have it on the cloud.
Um, yeah, it just sounded like, you
know, they, they were the better team.
They fucking came in. They
were ready to go. We weren't,
and we got behind early in
and, and we didn't win the
game, you know, I don't know.
I want to be seven and three. I don't know
what the fuck everybody's is. You know,
this guy just goes, it's just, just
a blip on the radar as it were,
played 700 ball.
That's how high the fuck standards.
So anyways, um, have a,
I think the titans just won a fucking
championship according to Dion Lewis.
You know, I don't get it. I love
that guy. But like I was, you know?
Okay.
You know what I mean?
I like it.
I don't understand why people
say shit like that. In November,
if you learned anything in New England,
you know that November you didn't
win anything. You won a game.
That's it. Congratulations.
I got to tell you though,
I couldn't help but think about that
lunatic that I saw in that sports bar in
New York City a few weeks ago when the
Patriots were playing the chiefs and now
that guy was just yelling, go and
fucking, you know, this is it.
This is how it is. Now you guys are
over looking around the bar. It's over.
Right? I can't imagine. I was psyched.
He was yesterday when the Patriots loss
and the chiefs one cause now I believe
the chiefs have a two game lead despite
head to head. You know, we won the game,
but like that's a really good look for
them. If we got to try to beat them again.
Uh, in Kansas City, well the cheeks
finally pushed their way through.
I gotta be honest, if the chiefs still
get through, if they do get past us,
if we can actually make it there,
if I can fucking hear myself and this
fucking piece of shit. Microphone.
MMM.
If they do beat us or whatever that,
that,
that will be the team that I root for
in the Superbowl because Jesus Christ,
they m and a one and since like
fucking Bart Starr was in the league,
I think he might have just retired.
By the way,
the last great number 15 at quarterback
brightstar no offense to Neil Lomax.
MMM.
Anyways, what else? I
am done for the year.
People with road dates other than this
little trip I have to take to New York to
promote F is for family season three,
which comes out in
November 30th on Netflix.
Um,
I mean Tom
and I ain't doing fucking shit
except hanging out with my daughter.
You know what I,
I
okay.
We are relative. Ours got out, got her
out one of those electric fucking cars,
you know, that they can sit in. I came
home and I put that thing together.
It was fucking hilarious.
She got on the thing,
she didn't get it and took a couple of
times just pushing the button and then
she just,
she actually took a finger off the button,
laughed and clapped her hands.
Like this is the shit. So
okay.
You know, cause one of my big
days is a dad coming up. I Dunno.
Maybe depending on how tall she is,
sometime when she's around 11 or 12.
So I'm going to teach her
how to drive my truck,
which shifts a three on the column,
you know,
which no fucking kid in l for the most
part knows how to drive a stick anymore.
Forget about one in the column.
So I think it'd be pretty bad ass
if I teach her how to do that.
And that's something when I was a kid,
my dad used to do that.
He used to take us down to the South
Shore Plaza when I was like 12 years old,
11 and 12.
And I go down there.
Okay.
Yeah. 1978, uh,
Chevy Chevette four speed transmission.
And that was back when,
um,
okay.
The uh, the mall was closed on
Sunday cause everybody, you know,
allegedly was going to church and
on the seventh day God rested and,
and you know, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, all that shit. So, you know,
you couldn't sell any liquor,
you couldn't sell any booze. Um,
you couldn't be open like
grocery stores would be open.
But that was basically it. And, uh,
they had like Sunday hours, you know.
So we used to go down there
in the empty a parking lot
and he would, she taught all his
kids out of drive down there.
We learned on a stick shift.
And I remember when I went to go get my
driver's license, I took it on a stick.
I think it was that car. Now we would've
got rid of it by that. No, no, no,
that's right. That'll, we
still had it. We still had it.
1984 would only be six years old,
even though a fucking tree fell on it.
We got it fixed. Yeah.
I went down and took in.
I don't remember the guy made me park
on a hill, you know, doing that shit.
And I was like, ah, fuck.
All right, here we go.
Just don't stall out here and
then you're going to be fine.
You've got to be fine.
It's one of the few tests that I passed.
Okay.
During those years,
everything else,
everything else that I guess really
fucking matter that would have led to a
nicer car.
I failed.
But then I,
I started doing comedy at all.
Boy,
everything happened for me. I got to
play at the Chicago theater. Everybody
for foreign, credible shows. I want
to thank everybody that came out.
We had such a great time.
Um, when we were there,
we didn't make it to the Liar's
club. I, as you can tell,
I've been fighting off a cold and it just,
the last time we went to
the Liar's club and man,
I was there till like four in the fucking
morning and didn't wake up till five
in the afternoon and then did
a show at the Chicago theater.
I felt like it was breakfast time.
I had literally just had
eggs and walked on stage.
And these poor people who have been
working all fucking day, Anna came out,
they're like this fucking bum
silicon shelda cause I'm a pro.
I'm fucking with you.
Anyways. Um, we ate it,
this place,
a new place we went to in Chicago.
Splays Gibsons and we got a stake
creamed spinach was fucking unbelievable.
And then in the end I got to get the name
of this fucking thing that these guys
said. They go, do you want dessert? And
you know, when you go out and get a steak,
you know, if you get like the filet
minion and it's the smart way to go,
but there's no flavor in it.
It's really bland.
They was going to have a
lead dipping sauces with it.
So I got some bone in Ribeye.
I hate that thing like fucking Fred
Flintstone. So now I'm sitting there,
even though we didn't get potatoes or
anything, I'm still, I'm fucking leaning.
I eat the whole thing. I should have cut
it in half. I didn't fucking leading.
And then these guys come over and they
were like, hey you do you want dessert?
And we'll like, Nah, Nah, Nah, we're good,
we're good. And they were like, no, no.
So some of the wages went to the show
last night. They want to bring you over a,
they want to bring you over
a fucking desert. Right?
Trying to find this Gibson's
menu. Chicago. Hang on a second.
I got to, I have to upload a
fucking picture of this thing.
They brought this God damn piece of cake.
It's fucking piece of cake. All
that. I swear to God. It was like,
it was like a whole cake.
Something like Banana Dream Boat. When
I saw the menu, I was saying to my,
Oh somebody, I forget who
I said and he's like, go,
I'll give you 20 bucks if
you just fucking order this.
Just cause I want to hear you say it
out loud. Gibson's menu. All right.
What is it called? Hair. Hang on. Hang on.
All right, here's the menu. What do
we got here? The meaning of life cake.
That wasn't it. Pumpkin Pie, but any
cream pie. Ah, yeah. Then fuck it.
Habit.
Okay.
With something like Banana Dream Boat.
I already know what it was,
but it was also,
it was these birthday and we
took him out to breakfast. Right.
And we ended up getting them. They
know we go, it's his birthday.
So it was breakfast and they brought
over like some fucking one of those
chocolate whipped cream.
Uh
Yeah,
fucking waffles or whatever.
Okay.
Can we sang happy birthday to him is
loud as humanly possible in the thing.
Just getting right in his face. And I
was actually joking with furs. He has go,
you know what I got?
That's why guys are funny because if we
were women that actually would have been
sincere.
He was just sitting there
fucking embarrassed to shit.
It was such a great time.
So, um, anyways,
I'll be honest with you, I really
don't have a lot to fucking talk about.
I've been just fighting off this God damn
cold. Oh I know. And I can talk about,
so when I was in, yeah, when
I was in Chicago, you know,
I told my travel agent,
I go book me,
book me in a Nice Hotel, close
to the fucking um, the venue.
Now I'm a fancy man at this point,
so I don't even handle any of that shit.
I finally learned how to delegate stuff
cause I was doing my whole career.
I was like fucking Chuck Berry.
The way he drive up to the venue in his
own car with his fucking guitar in the
backseat. That's what
I was doing, you know,
which adds a ton of fucking
responsibility and shit.
Cause then you got to tell your
openers were all where the hotel is.
You got to go in and you got to check out.
I never had a fucking tour manager.
Never did that shit. Cause uh, you know,
I'm an antisocial son of a bitch and all
I'm thinking is this is just going to
be another fucking guy I have to talk
to and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I'm just going to be that down to
Earth fucking guy who just fucking blah
blah blah. You know, just
comes walking in. Well that's
what I did. And guess what?
Now I'm getting text messages from
people who work at fucking Avis,
where I rented a car, you
know, fucking eight years old,
you remember me,
you rented a Ford Focus.
You could to get stupid
stupid fucking move.
That's what being down to earth gets you,
gets a bunch of people fucking
calling you up. You know the did,
she had a two second interaction with her,
right?
So if you learn anything on this podcast,
all right?
As you move up the ladder,
it's very important to forget
where you came from. All right?
And what you want to do is treat people
who you feel your ego tells you are not
a year level. You want to
treat them less than. Okay.
But there is, there is a
certain level, you know.
Yeah.
Well you have to kind of dial it back.
Like I went out and I did
a fucking meet and greet,
you know one time when I was in Reno this
guy goes take a picture of my wife and
I got find any reaches in his jacket
to fucking take out a camera and a nine
millimeter fell on the fucking ground
and I pointed at the gun and went oh shit.
And watched him pick it back up again.
Like a fucking,
I should have kicked it.
I should have done some sorta Steven
Seagal move. But you know that's,
I mean I didn't grow up around guns.
I was just like,
Oh I think you dropped something. Serve.
Fortunately it was an off duty cop,
although he ran out of there cause
it was a native American reservation.
They weren't, we were on their land
in union, not allowed to bring a, a,
a weapon in there.
Probably your specialty as a white man
considering what happened the first time
around,
they probably don't want fucking white
people coming in with guns anymore. Right.
So, um, there was that,
there was another time I had a group of
people followed me home from the venue
and I got out of the car and there
was the, hey, bill is, I got out.
I was just like, oh fuck, what's
going to happen? You know,
that little mini heart attack.
Are you going to kill me? Oh,
you just want a picture,
right? So anyways,
okay.
Um,
I'm one of those people,
I know what airline of flying as I drive
to the airport, I do that Shit, right?
So we're on our way to Chicago,
uh, like the night before.
So I asked my travel agent,
you know, where would stay?
And he said the Trump hotel and I was
like, Oh shit. All right, Trump hotel.
Donnay okay, so we fucking stay
there man. And I didn't understand.
I know that people don't like
Donald Trump, but I don't want,
I didn't understand that they
also don't like his buildings
because the fucking jerk off his,
put his name on every building.
So now when people hate him, they,
they, you know, his name is there.
So they stand in front and they do all of
this fucking Shit, right? Like, you know,
fuck you done outside of the thing.
So anyway,
so we go in there, of course,
it's fucking incredible.
It's fucking beautiful. The service
was amazing. The food was incredible.
Everything. And there was great,
like, this is what he's good at.
This is what he should have stayed doing.
This is his wheelhouse.
You know what I mean? This is like
Elvis, keep singing. The songs do,
don't make the fucking movies.
So anyways,
okay.
We were saying in there all weekend,
we had a great fucking time, you know,
quick walk down to the,
uh, the, uh, the venue,
right? So I say to Nia, I go near, you
know, I go, you're not believe what?
I'm Sam standing in a Trump hotel. She
goes, no, not, I'm like, yeah, yeah,
I had him fucking, I didn't book
it. You know, I just, I show,
I worry about the shows now.
This is great.
I don't have to fucking think
about anything. So she's
breaking my balls, right.
Going like, is it the greatest hotel
ever? You don't do on that show? I go,
you know, it's kind of fucking
nice. I'm not gonna lie to you.
So I actually took a video,
okay.
Um, of the, of the Roman, all that
and the view I had and everything,
and she wrote back to me,
she goes,
I got to admit that best
it makes it nice hotel.
So anyways, I, uh,
okay.
I ran into somebody that I knew at the,
at the airport, he's like, oh, you know,
where were you working with talking blah,
blah, blah, blah. And he's, you know,
somehow where I stayed came
up and I mentioned it to him,
so he starts breaking my balls.
He's like going, you know,
that guy's not a good person. It's like,
yeah, I agree with that. And he goes,
you should spend your money
elsewhere. And like, well look,
he's still fucking president.
So like me not staying there.
Is that somehow not going
to make him president? And
he's like, no. He's like, Oh,
you know a horrible fucking person
and Yada Yada Yada. And I go,
so where should I stay there?
The Hiltons,
the Sheridans like they're all good
people, aren't they all billionaires?
Like who the fuck do you think they voted
for? Like, yeah, you know, I don't know.
I've kind of bugged me a little bit with
everybody having to give everybody a
fucking lecture.
It's like you're really going to sit
here and as you hold the fucking apple
laptop computer,
have you ever read about them?
I'll tell you the ones that had people
leaping to their deaths at their fucking
sweat shop, cause they, they, they,
they had to work so much. It didn't,
you made so little, their
lives was so helpful. Helpless.
They were jumping out of the factory.
So they had to fucking putting nets
up around the fucking thing, you know?
And then they played soothing music and
then they considered possibly giving
them more money, which was
really the solution. So, I mean,
okay,
all the clothes I'm wearing,
what?
I really want to see the people's lives
who have to fucking put it together.
We wake up, we're going
to stop this. You know,
you gotta give me a lecture as we're
getting on a fucking plane that uses fuel.
Where do we get the fuel to
get it from the Middle East?
What the fuck's going on over there?
How many innocent people have died over
the bullshit that we're putting in this
fucking plane? Okay. While
we're trying to liberate them,
you know, so I dunno. It's just, it's
a, it's a, I understand. You know,
I dunno.
I don't like Donald Trump.
Okay.
Mostly just his racial views is
what really, you know, that's,
that's what I really don't like that guy.
Okay. I didn't fucking vote for the guy.
All right. Why don't we tell you this?
The guy makes a hell of a fucking hotel.
Okay.
I wish that's what he was still doing
exclusively. And I'm sure you guys are
gonna give me shit and some out, you know,
take out your frustration on him, on
me. The fact that I fucking, you know,
stayed there, but I'm
telling you, you know,
okay,
if you kind of play that fucking game,
you
got to, you got to do with
straight across the board,
where are you going to go pick and choose.
Okay.
Because you know that's another, that's
like another, like I feel like it's, it's,
it's almost the way,
like when you go to a,
when somebody goes to a comedy show
and they laugh at all the fucking jokes
until I drive across their front yard,
then all of a sudden I didn't do a joke
now and making statements and their
feelings are fucking hurt. It's like
if you really care to that level going,
this guy's a bad fucking person,
then I would say that you would really
be limiting that you should be staying at
some sort of mom and pop fucking hotel.
If you can find it
as you then go down and try to find
some organic fucking guy that's not a
corporate farmer, you know,
cause they've poisoned the food.
I mean you start going
down that road or maybe,
I guess you could just pick your battle.
Okay.
I have no idea. But I will tell you
this, that hotel was so fucking nice.
I actually weighed my wife getting
mad at me. I just call I Sydney,
are you gonna get mad if I stay at
another one of these? And she laughed.
She goes, yes, you fucking assholes.
I said, all right, fair enough.
So whenever I'm wanting done what had
done like the titans beat the Patriots,
congratulations on your
huge victory in November.
You know,
they should have a trophy
for fucking teams like that.
And I can't say I'm not picking them.
I may pick on the titans.
I just didn't like what Deon Louis said,
you know,
you didn't talk any shit before the
fucking game and then you fucking win and
now you're going to run your fucking Yap.
The Fuck Outta here.
You hate this organism. You, you just,
you know what it is. You know what it is.
He said, fucking, you know,
he's fucking mad that he wants to please.
All I hear is I still want to
play for the Patriots. Well,
use it to page agenda. They got a
woody way here. They got the flu,
whatever the door is working
with blah, blah, blah, blah.
And all of a sudden when you
get caught up in the Washer,
that all of a sudden the
patriots are fucking assholes.
Patriot's day at a Trump hotel.
Some of them do. Anyways.
Um, anyways, is there a
Clinton hotel I could stay at?
Maybe get back in your
people's good graces.
Jesus Christ.
We got to meet to Robin. That
one. Oh, Bill, come on. You know,
I just feel like you're better than that.
Hey,
let's bring people back together here.
Um,
where was the, what the fuck is
this story? I was Google news. Hey,
about those Bros, man, they're
starting to play out, right? Oh,
the side of the fucking put it
together. I watched them play, uh,
the Toronto game when I was
there in Chicago and I had
a flashback when I played
the Chicago theater with Jamie,
nor a Jim Brewer in David
tell on the antisocial tour.
I can't believe it was seven fucking
years ago. And I remember I was in uh,
the green room.
Yeah. At the end of the, and I was late
to the meet and greet cause I was watching
the fucking Bruins win the Stanley
Cup.
Yeah.
Former Clinton advisor,
Hillary will run in 2020.
If she ever becomes president,
that's going to be a great 30 for 30.
MMM.
Cause she's going to run again.
She feels she's thinks it's her job.
Please Democrats don't fuck it. Oh my God.
How many fucking times? How many times?
How many times are you gonna play Marty
Ball? Can you get somebody in there?
All right.
There's gotta be somebody else.
They can't tell me.
The Democrats are going to be dumb
enough to hit shift fucker wagon again.
How many times?
How many times do you put that person
under center and you come away with a loss
before you don't go to your second string
quarterback. That's all I'm asking.
This has gotta be the most politically
charged podcast I've ever done.
Where do I get off?
Not Paying attention for getting
to submit an absentee ballot,
telling people who
should run for president.
Where the fuck was that
story I was looking for?
Oh Wow. The guy was in the voice
of the computer in 2001 die.
Yeah.
Do you have to Abbott there was a woman
out there was such a big fan of that
that fucking wanted them to
talk like that during sex. Um,
sorry.
What the fuck is this story?
I was looking for some fucking guy in
Texas broke into a house and bled out
cause he cut his arm on the window.
I'll, I can take is how nice
was to stuff in the house.
Okay.
Getting Dizzy.
Oh look at that vase.
Um, anyways. Is it time for the Oh Geez.
It's time for the advertising
there. Um, oh, when our hotel,
that was Jesus Christ.
What a fucking hotel.
The steam room was incredible.
A lot of these hotels you go to write
other than the festival in Milwaukee,
you go into the steam room and they, uh,
they always have it on like we'd
all want to hurt anybody level.
Okay.
You know, Trump doesn't give a
shit. He'll fuck hill. You know,
you'll put kids in cages.
That guy does not give a fuck.
You think this Steve's
not going to be hot.
I'm fucking eucalyptus was like
fucking versus he was like,
ah, hey. Its burden by eyes. Right.
There was so much eucalyptus in
there. I, I dunno, I felt like Yo,
when you chew like a really like
winter fresh God, more like,
like minty fucking gum.
That's what my eyeballs felt like.
MMM.
It was tremendous. Where the fuck
am I going to know? I'm trying,
I'm trying to find the advertising. All
right, here we go. Oh look who's here?
Everybody.
Zip.
Okay.
Yeah.
There are jobs sites that make you
want to make you wait for the right
candidates to apply to your job.
Not Smart capital letters.
Not Smart. You know what's not
smart? I'm yelling all the capitals,
making the lottery the centerpiece
of your retirement plan. Oh, Jesus.
Oh Man.
I had friends like that.
Okay,
dude, what are you doing after high
school? I'm just going to work. Well,
what are you going, how are you
going to add? I'll hit the lottery.
I'm going to hit the fucking lottery kid.
Zip.
Go to ziprecruiter.com yeah,
you know where it is. Smart. Uh,
going to ziprecruiter.com/bird
to hire the right person. All Zip
doesn't depend on candidates finding you.
It finds them for you.
It's powerful. Matching technology
scans thousands of resumes,
identifies people with the right skills,
education,
and experience for your job and actively
invites them to apply so you get
qualified candidates fast.
That's why zip.
Okay is rated number one by employers
in the u s this rating comes from the
hiring sites on trust
pilot with over 1000 views.
Okay?
Now, right now I apologize
for being congested. I know
it's getting annoying now.
Right now my listeners
can try ZipRecruiter for
free at this exclusive web
address. Zip, R, e, c r u, I t e R.
Dot com slash burr that's
ziprecruiter.com/bar zip.
The smartest way to hire. Oh look
who's here. Dollar Shave Club, dude.
Dollar Shave Club has anything. Everything
you need to feel and smell your best.
You'd never have to go to the store.
That's what I'm doing from here on out.
I'm just screaming.
Capitals capitalized words in the copy
because evidently they want me to a
stress case. You missed it the first
time you have to go to a store.
Okay.
That's because they deliver everything
you need right to your dealer and they
keep you fully stocked or what you use so
you don't run out. Here's how it works.
Dollar Shave club hubs,
everything you need to get ready,
no matter what you're getting ready for.
They have you covered.
Head to toe for your hair, your
skin, your face, you name it,
they have it and they had this new
program where they automatically keep you
stocked up on products you use.
You determine what you
want and when you want it.
Then it shows right up to your door for
once a month to once every six months,
depending on how filthy you are.
You fucking animal plus with
their handsome discount.
The more you buy, the more
you save. And Right now,
dollar shave club has a bunch of status
sets you can drive for just $5 like oral
care kit. After that, uh,
the restock box ships regular sized
products at regular price gets you status.
And for just $5 right
now@dollarshaveclub.com slash bar,
that's dollar shave club. Dot.
Cobb slash. Bar. All right,
probably more two more.
Alright,
stamps.com everybody,
you know these days you could practically
get everything on demand like our
podcast. Listen whenever you want,
when it's convenient for you.
Did you know you can even
get postage on demand?
All you need to stamps.com with stamps.com
you can access all of the service at
the post office right
from your desk by imprint.
Rare us postage for any
letter or any package,
just click print mail and you're done.
Stamps dot Cobb.
We'll even send you a digital scale.
You can wear your letters and packages
and print the exact amount of postage
every time. Four week trial includes
postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com before you do
anything else, your kid can eat later.
Click on the radio and the microphone
radio microphone at the top of the
homepage.
Sorry.
And type it bar that stamps.com
at your bar for reads.
Why did it say four reads
makes me feel like I missed one.
All right. Oh, lastly,
but not leastly lastly,
but not leastly my bookie or
you daughter Ray, my bookie.
Sure.
Watch your football is fun,
but it's more really the daily with
your little action. You the gala,
it wasn't matching. Come early in
the quarter. Go to fucking bed books.
He took cup.
Guys,
you've heard me talking about this for
a week and some of you are still on the
sidelines. Uh, whether you're an expert
or a rookie, you should be bed net. My,
I'll get over here. Put
some [inaudible] equal. Uh,
if you're the kind of guy that likes to
bet a little and when a lot like playing
the numbers on Roulette, uh,
you can create a big parlay,
pick three teams to win and if he hit
all three, he could turn $100 into 600.
If you don't, you're going
to lose a little north of
$100. Just to let you know,
there's, there's so much to bet on
college basketball and football, NBA, Nhl,
custom props, even east sports.
You could better video games.
You name it. My bookie, how are you doing?
All right is the one of the best, uh,
is the one bad I know you'll
be happy with all year.
I recommend these guys
because they pay me. Say it.
My bookie I you doing has
been in business for years.
They've got great online reviews and
their mobile site is easy to use.
Sign up this weekend.
My bookie, I in my book,
He will give you a uh,
a 50% deposit boulders to
jumpstart your bank roll.
It's a great way to bank
even more money when you win.
Also make sure to follow at my bed.
My bookie on Twitter,
uh, they personally respond
to every mentioned ed data.
Not to mention that they give,
they've given away more than $10,000
in free money to their followers.
This football season.
You'll be the first to know as soon
as the odds of props are posted,
whatever props are,
uh,
don't miss out on one of the best
weeks to bet on sports this year.
Log On to my book.
He right now use Promo Code,
a Promo Code you had to get,
I guess that's supposed to be burr.
I don't have the fucking
Promo Code and he get 15,
a 50% deposit bonus.
That's Promo Code Code Joe Rogan
about that. You play, you win,
you get paid.
Okay
fucking I can give you a promo code.
Oh fucking pass it on to one of the
biggest sweethearts of this fucking
business. You know something. I, you
know these fucking fires out here, right?
A couple of, you know, good friends
of mine had to flee that shit.
So fortunately for the last I heard their
houses are all right, but good lord,
those winds whipping around
like there's fucking literally fire
tornadoes. I mean, it's just like,
it's just insane. But you know,
we choose to live out here.
Who is the fucking hassle that decided
to put the entertainment business out
here? Uh, you know what you're even, he
can't even bitch about the fires out here.
That's how nice the weather is.
It's just one of those things.
God's Never gonna let you chill.
Okay. Ah, you like in this,
you like in this, he here's a fucking
fire tornado. Just to keep you honest,
just to remind you not to be a cunt.
Uh,
anyways,
I am so fucking site to be home.
I am not doing shit. I'm really gonna
for the first time in your life,
try and rest up,
uh,
get some sleep. I love the
holiday season. Doobie Doobie.
Do at school to lead pup.
Look who's here.
It's your fucking pop was bad on the road.
You remember me?
I look like a stranger. I
begged God so far. Can Log.
Why do you cry when you see me?
Cause I'm absentee.
Oh yeah. See I don't, I
don't want to be that guy
and completely changing the way I work
and all of that type of shit. So, uh,
thank God for facetime.
But I came home and my daughter was just
waking up from a nap and I poke my head
in and she gave me a big smile
and you know, change, turn,
all that type of stuff.
When she was laying on the changing
table and she reached up and she gave me
like, I swear to God,
like 12 hugs in a row.
It was playing with my beard and just
looking at me, I could see it arise.
She legitimately miss me and
it's just like, there's no,
there's no fucking way that, uh,
I'm gonna, you know, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna,
I'm going to start working smart.
MMM. Cause I get, I get it.
I think I really get it.
No, I do. I'm not arguing with my wife.
She gives me the honey do list. I just
fucking do it because I'll tell you,
that's still the only way you're
going to be happy and your,
your marriage truly happy is if you just
do every fucking thing they want you to
do. I'll tell you, you do that,
that women are so easy to get along with.
All right, so my next, you
know, I got like a quick little,
like a three,
four day run up,
do a benefit back east and then promoting
season three of f is for family.
Okay.
Uh,
going to be doing Seth bias,
a a old friend of mine from
back in the day. I actually, uh,
got to know him way back when I was on
breaking bad and we were both huge fans
of the show and we would fucking geek
out sending each other emails trying to
figure out where the show was going to
go next. And it was such a great show.
I was actually on it for
a couple episodes that he,
I couldn't even figure out where I
was going to go. Uh, but whatever.
So I'll be very excited to,
uh,
okay.
Do I get on that show?
They listen to this podcast.
I imagine he'll give me shit for
staying at the Trump Chicago.
MMM.
I would've stayed at the Obama, but he,
you know, he doesn't fucking have it,
you know? Does he get a fucking ice
cream stand so I can be a, you know?
Yeah.
Is it, this is not partisan.
What would that be?
If I actually stayed at
a Trump hotel and ate it?
Obama's ice cream stand then when I
truly be independent or I'd be called a
centrist.
And who made that ice cream?
How many cows had to die to make that
ice cream? Well, Bill, they don't die.
They melt them. Well, you know what?
I guess I don't know what I'm
talking about anyways. Uh,
when in Thailand towered a bill?
Where did Tallinn Estonia try
the pancakes in compressor.
Just do it. All right. Well you like
Nike. There's another green hope.
Everybody likes it. Jordan's right? I
do. What do you get into Jordan too?
You're doing bad injuries.
Go to the fucking factory.
Okay.
Jesus Christ. I mean, I don't
understand how they get,
they just fucking get away
with all of that shit.
Yeah,
yeah. That you can just treat people like
that. Why don't you fucking, you know,
fly commercial.
You can bump up the price of
the sneakers a little bit,
but went back to the day when I was a kid,
like shit was made here and it wasn't
ridiculously expensive cause they was
going, hey, you want us to
make shit over here? Okay.
It's going to be $9 million for
some shoe strings. It's like,
that's cause you don't want to take any
money out of your pocket. You can't,
sorry.
Um, all right. This
should be a global union,
which you'll never be able to do.
You'll never be able to get that done.
Uh,
talent Astonia here we go.
Okay.
A Global Union of just regular people
against these fucking rich content.
That should be the new world order.
All right.
Okay.
Yeah, but then, you know, yeah. You know,
the thing is you can't have one side
either side, having too much power.
Because back in the day when unions,
what really powerful here,
let me look what you did.
They didn't take advantage of that.
They weren't guilty of kind of driving
some of these factories like to,
I can't deal with these fucking cuts.
You know I've dealt with you
and you'd fucking houses.
I tried to shoot specials in, in, in these
places. They gouge the shit out of you.
You show up and they're like made a toy.
You just gotta be 20 fucking fucking
people to put a mic stand at a stool on a
stage because that's
how many people we need.
When a a Dave Matthews shows up,
you know,
well they bring in Carter Beauford is
fucking 900 piece drum set and I'm showing
up.
You don't microphone bike stayed at his
stool and I've got to have fucking four,
four guys gotta be up there.
You had peak for fucking guys and
everything goes through the God damn roof.
Yeah.
So maybe corporations aren't bad.
Maybe they're just human
beings with too much freedom.
Okay.
I think that's what it is.
Where do you get too much
free to be acting like a
cunt? White people. All right.
Talent. Wikipedia. Guilty
as charged. All right.
Travel Guide. Well, let's
check out the weather here. Oh,
fucking cove. Talent. Astonia
whether I'm wait these pictures.
This is 40 degrees rating.
Okay.
That's a bad. Alright. Images.
Oh my God.
Okay.
I am not showing any of these
pictures to my wife. Well,
I know this has to be the
picture as downtown area.
Yeah,
but still what a downtown it is.
Oh my God.
Okay.
This is how much I love my wife.
Want to go to places like this.
I actually feel guilt.
Oh my God.
It's fucking beautiful.
Okay.
Oh, I bet they'll have great
fucking stories to the studio.
World War II. This is all you do.
What? Where? Where were you guys?
What side of the fence?
Okay.
World War II.
Yeah.
Oh,
did they side with you would have stayed
in those countries to decision they had
to make,
do I go with style in order to go with
fucking Hitler to the biggest fucking
mass murdering lunatics of all time.
You know,
sometimes you just not left
with the good fucking choice,
like a last election.
Sometimes it's 2:00 AM at a bar.
You just got to pick someone.
Although I don't know if you know,
okay,
you still have to go style it. You
know what I mean? Just, I mean, Hitler,
Hitler was d,
he's Hitler's is that dude?
He's the fucking Freddie Mercury
of mass murderers, you know?
Okay.
He had like a 12 octave evil range.
You don't have a lot of ways Stella.
He kind of looks like Tom Selleck a little
bit, right. It lives just a little be,
I'd fucking, anyways, before the outbreak
of the Second World War, Germany,
the Soviet Union's side,
the germy and Soviet nonaggression pact
and some little dose fucker with a does
pants sweeper have a mustache. He broke
that Denny concerning the practitioner.
That's gotta be one of the most fucked
up things ever that he actually thought
he was gonna beat Russia.
That little ass fucking country was
going to go with there. I mean, you know,
they will come in over there with
their fucking Mercedes Benz and Porsche
fucking machine guns and planes had
tanks. I mean, you could see why, uh,
the Republic of his sone,
it declared neutrality in the war,
but fell under the Soviet
sphere of influence. Do too.
Yeah.
Oh my God. The Mala Tav Ribbentrop pact.
Okay.
You know, it's funny. If you
watch jeopardy, somebody will, uh,
what is the Molotov Ribbentrop pact?
He only gets 50 points for of that.
Uh,
so they end up being occupied by the
Soviet Union in 1940 mass political
arrests. So he's still got fucked
deportations and executions followed.
Oh, Jesus. And people who it. But what
about the Molotov Ribbentrop pact?
I have a little flyer here.
You want to look at it?
Jesus Christ,
whenever you read the sheet,
you just realize how fucking lucky you
are to be living in wherever the hell you
live in. If this is, if there's
not shit like this going on,
uh,
I love the guy from Estonia has got to be,
hey, listen, man, I just told you to get,
get some fucking pancakes.
I didn't tell you to go that that deep.
Or let's look it up here.
Compressor Astonia
style it back here.
Compressor
pancakes.
Is it a Mercedes Benz?
Okay,
so it's like German pancakes.
Oh Shit. Okay. Oh Man.
Okay.
Oh,
it looks life and fluffy.
Yeah,
it's got a pound of butter on it. I don't
know how that is or the metric system.
Yeah,
so like a caramelized fucking piece
of banana. All right. I'm there.
Jesus Christ.
I better start.
The only thing that sucks
about this tour is a Molly.
I've just doing one nighters the whole
way. Like I'm going to miss so much shit.
Just going to kind of drive by. But you
know, I got a kid now, so, okay. Poland.
All right. So I'm getting pancakes at
compressor and Estonia. Poland. Hey,
bald headed. Fuck his is
from the world. You know,
when you're follicly challenged like
myself, you really don't feel like you,
you just, you're just a man without
a country. Uh, me and my buddy,
a huge fans living in Poland.
I can't fucking wait to go there because
I met this woman a long time ago when I
was on the road and I think I was
an eighth. Well, we started talking.
I was on a flight was delayed and
she said she was from Poland. I was,
I did stand up. She goes, yeah, they got
clubs over there. And I was like, yeah.
She told me how you wanted to actually
along uh Oh by geographies bad now she
was telling me that they
have all these Colin, Colin,
Paul Oled, Bup, Bup, bup, bup, bup.
What body of water is that right?
Is it the Baltic Sea?
Okay.
Poland,
see
geography, a pug. Baltic Sea. Look
at all Billy fucking globe head.
Um, the Baltic Sea. Yes. There
was some towns along there.
She was like, oh, that's what you want
to play, but I'm not, I'm going to,
I think it would be in Warsaw.
Okay.
You all right there Fred, right in the
middle of the country, I believe. Anyways,
meet a buddy,
a huge fans of Poland,
and we hear you are coming to a
city in this shit hole country. Oh,
I don't fucking tell me that.
It'd be nice if we knew when
the dates were so we could, uh,
so we know if we could make it,
what are the chances you could tell us
all the best and go fuck yourself. Yeah,
that'd be,
it's all been announced in a week.
It was all supposed to be announced at
the same time, but Germany was all like,
we need to announce it now.
Right. At my age, it was like, uh,
why do you feel you need the, what else
are now trying to do Jackie Mason, right.
German talker to the Jew. Um,
so he ended up backing down.
He's like, all right, you
fucking load of Texas.
Announce it when you want to.
And they did and it went great.
So it tickets got sold over
there. Uh, anyways, uh,
best friends, it will be all be announced
in a week. All right. All right.
Best friends with best friends,
wife from a lady.
Oh, hello Billy Baldwin. I
get it. I get it once again,
making me feel bad about
my mood shaped head.
Yeah.
Um,
recently I've been posting pictures and
videos on my Instagram that are.dot,
dot.
Not slutty.
Okay.
All right. So right there, there are
of a risky, okay, hang on a second.
I gotta I gotta I gotta clear my nose
here. Hang on a second. All right.
This is just one of these things where
if I lay down my nose just fucking just
blocks up. But if I'm a
second I stand up, it's fine.
I don't want to stand it anyways.
All right, so you're posting these
pictures that are not slutty,
but I wouldn't show parents
either. Well, all right.
Okay. There is, there's a window in there.
There's a window in there cause
they're gonna be like you. You get,
your dress is too short. Come
on honey. What are you doing?
You get killing your father,
right?
I'm 26 years old and I had been feeling
very confident about myself and my body.
Good for you. I'm sick. I wish I
felt that they way above my head.
How can I,
when everybody makes fun of it.
I like my head and I
don't care what I believe.
Yeah.
Christina Aguilera said
it best when she said,
I am beautiful no matter what they say.
Right.
Okay.
And I believe her pussy was
as bald as the top of my head,
judging by some of her outfits.
You know what I mean? I mean,
the skirts was so slow. The hair would be
hanging out underneath. Right. Oh, pill.
Why? Why? Why do you have to be so
crass? Cause I'm not funny. You know,
when you're not funny, you go right
to the genitals. I mean, it's,
it's one of the oldest, oldest is
one of the oldest things in comedy.
I'm 26 years old and been
feeling good about my body.
I'm single with no boyfriend
or even dating. Can I get
down? I have a good time.
Go by a fucking suitcase full
of condoms and a jump on it.
Oh, sorry. Anyways, my friend.
Okay.
Anyways,
my friends since I was 16 has told me
that his wife has been uncomfortable with
us talking because she's seen my pictures.
Well,
yeah, you sound like you're
in the prime of your life.
You're obviously crushing it.
Uh,
she told them she feels insecure and
sees my pictures even before he does.
He's expressed that he may not be
my friend anymore because of this.
While he's doing the right thing, you
know, happy wife, happy life. Hey,
she ain't happy.
Nobody's going to be happy.
Uh,
why does he just unfollow,
unfollow.
You can you just do that and you guys
could be friends in a different way.
I don't know. It's weird. That's all
weird. I get where his wife's coming from.
Uh, she's, you know, if my wife
was Sunday, somebody, you know,
and he's keys, fucking posting
banana hammock pop pictures,
I don't feel like that would be too
comfortable with that. Right. Swing low,
sweet chariot. Sorry. Um,
she told me she feels insecure and
sees my pictures even before he does.
He has expressed that he may not be
friends anymore because of this. Sorry,
I had to reread that again.
But I know a lot of you guys watch reality
shows and they always come back and
show you what you just saw.
And this is not the first time I've
been blocked by male friends because now
this is where we need Nia
because their female counterparts,
our social media stalking me and
claiming I'm trying to get there, man,
I,
I've told to tone
down my posts are not right how I feel
because the girls take it personally and
take it out on my friends. Now
on some level, you know, you,
you to know what you're doing,
all right,
here's the, here's the deal, okay?
Because men are weak,
women are fucking gorgeous.
There are certain rules that you
do have to follow, all right?
And for you to be as beautiful as you
are and feeling as confident as you are
about your body, it posted those
pictures. Nothing wrong with that,
but when you're,
we start being friends with all these
guys that are in relationships like you're
single. Go be friends with guys
that aren't in relationships,
okay?
It's, it's a, it's a tough thing. It's
a tough thing. It's not your fault.
You're pretty and you feel like
fucking shown and off a little bit.
Not Too slutty. Not To fucking
dad will appreciate this. Uh,
anyways, I've been told to
tone it down or, or not to
write. I feel blah, blah, blah.
Uh,
are these my real friends or do
girls have legit reasons to be upset?
Yours truly a huge fan and
love to Nia and the baby.
Uh,
okay.
Fuck. I might have to do an epilogue
on this and getting the, uh,
you know what I'm going to
happen. I'm going to answer
this and on Thursday, Neil,
we'll give her answer. Look at that
teasing the next episode like a pro.
Um, listen, if you're,
if you're not passively,
aggressively, you know,
okay.
Being a Dick Tease,
just cause you liked that attention
and you're just legitimately just
okay.
You know,
like how you look and saying how you feel
that then I don't think you're wrong,
but I don't think they're wrong either.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
I don't know how it works with women,
but when a woman is more attractive
or it makes another woman feel less
attractive and it's talking
to the dead guy. Yeah.
That's going to be guys get like that.
Right? Some guy comes up, you know,
he's all fucking jacked. He's got
pigment, he's got hair. I mean,
how am I going to feel,
you know,
you don't think I'm going to truck and
puff up my little freckled fucking chest,
you know,
try to recite some line from a
fucking Sylvester Stallone movie.
Huh? A, are you like Deb
apple? So whatever the fuck
it is, just combined movies.
Um, yeah. Like this is what I would do.
I would just say I would respect
the women in these relationships.
And what you need to do is,
uh,
you need to find some guys
that are single to follow you.
All right?
Knowing what comes with
that, like, oh my God,
you look so a lot like this once you're
going to be getting, uh, you know,
but I wouldn't worry about it. I mean,
these are great problems to have. I mean,
you can be fucking ugly living under a
bridge crying every Friday and Saturday
night because they'll wants
to go near you. So, you know,
it's nice to have a lot of suitors.
Uh,
okay.
I, I, if I was you, I would
just, I would, I would expand.
Okay.
Uh,
my friend circle.
All right.
And also, you know, what can you say
that you weren't posting like that?
And then recently I've been posting
pictures of videos. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. See?
So everything was cool until
you started doing that.
So that's what changed seeds. Sometimes
when you change as a person, you,
you lose a few friends. So
that's, that's what I would say.
You're not historically been doing this.
Okay.
You know, I don't know what
your head like. You're fucking,
I sell real estate head shot on there.
Okay.
The family values one, and now
you're out there like, what the fuck?
I'm only going to be young ones.
Okay,
we're going to go out
and have a good time.
Then all of a sudden these people
locked out of relationships. Yeah, yeah.
You're gonna have a problem.
So I don't necessarily think you're doing
anything wrong. I just think that, uh,
if that's the way you're going to be,
you can't be around guys that are in
relationships. And in fairness to them,
you're going to be causing them to
get into a lot of God damn arguments.
All right?
Okay.
And I guarantee you at least one of them
is thinking about one of your pictures
when he bends his fucking girl over.
I mean, I'm just telling you, okay.
As a guy that that's what's happening.
And the woman knows it,
especially when they mutter your
name, bumble it. What did you say?
I said, uh, we should
be shared more stuff.
What is sharing my life with you?
A husband having an emotional
affair while we are living in Tokyo.
Uh,
Hey, Billy boat act. How
do you know boat act?
India? That's a fucking inside
joke there. You fucking boat act.
That's an insult to a comedian.
Uh,
things have been difficult with my
husband and I since we moved to Tokyo from
the u s uh,
went through his phone to find him
messaging his new teammate all day.
Not just about work stuff either.
I don't know if it would be flirting,
but it made me uncomfortable.
There are things,
he's messaging her before he even
tells me. Yeah. None of that is cool.
I confronted him,
but he swears to me he would never
do something like that to me.
What should I do next?
It's hard to not want to go through his
phone or wonder what they're up to at
work.
Thank you so much and go fuck yourself.
I would just tell him that
because of his fucking behavior,
you now have urges to
go through his phone.
All right?
Would you be comfortable if I was
texting a guy that I work with that much?
If I was telling him personal stuff
about myself before I told you it's not
fucking cool. That's not cool on any
fucking level. And you're 100% right.
Uh, what you do about it? I don't know.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what the move is there.
You gotta. Yeah, you gotta
fucking head. Jesus Christ. Ah,
relationships. Aren't they fun? All this
technology, all the new fucking ways.
So this is all,
there's so many fucking people out there,
men and women who we not doing
the shit that they would be doing,
posting fucking sexy pictures of yourself
at the whole fucking world. Could see,
do you really sell fucking nuts
set is that you can do that now.
Then there's somebody can actually in
their house look at these sexy photos of
you in a robe jerk and their deck
to it and then their wife walks in.
What are you doing? Oh, I was
just pointing down low shit.
Yeah.
Uh, I think the way that you would
be are interacting right now.
We were never meant to interact this way.
Uh,
it is like the level of voyeurism
that is just fucking mainstream.
It's not healthy. All right. And I'm not,
I'm not wagging my finger at anybody
here. I mean, I stayed at a Trump hotel.
Who am I to tell anybody
anything? Uh, anyways,
tog cruise is added again.
Yeah.
All right. Y'All bill, read this
on Twitter. Read this on Twitter.
Wanted to hear your reaction.
You think Tommy boy can pull it off?
It's Tom Cruise. Whatever you're gonna say
yes, he can get you fucker. Pull it off.
I know you're not a fighter pilot,
but I figured you're in the aviation
world and understand this stuff. Okay.
That's a major, I have a private pilot's
license and I have under 200 hours.
Uh, but I'll tell you I'm a hell of a
pilot for a lot of time. I have, okay.
That bar,
that boy Tommy Cruz is added again,
the actor who insists on doing his
own stunts might be taking things even
further on for Topcon
to Aka top gun maverick.
This is a,
this is a rubric for now because it comes
from an anonymous source over at the
Daily Mail. In other words, it never
happened, but I'll continue reading.
But Cruz apparently was to re re
really fly a fighter jet in the movie,
not just pretend if this is true,
we'll know about it soon because Cruz
is never shy about publicly about
publicity regarding his craziest studs.
I certainly wouldn't be surprised that
this turned out to be the real deal
though.
Um,
yeah,
no,
it's not publicity.
He's selling the movie and if he fucking
flew a helicopter nose down and do a
goddamn ravine, yeah, they're going to
talk about it. Um, yeah. That's not true.
There's no way.
That's fucking true.
Okay.
I actually did a little research on this
question in f 35 costs just south of
$100 million. You're not going to
stick a fucking actor in there.
Uh, now they might, if he could fly
two people in it, which I don't know,
they might put him up there with
the fucking instructor. Yeah.
Okay.
Okay. And let him fly the
fucking thing around and uh,
they could do it that way and then
just digitally remove that guy from the
fucking phone. The, uh, the,
the, the shot or whatever.
I Dunno, just Tom Cruise.
If anybody's going to do it,
I would imagine it would be him,
but there's no fucking way they're
going to let them fly one solo.
Okay.
I mean, that's probably the entire
budget of the fucking movie.
If he crashes that thing.
Okay.
He's going to parachute out. I Dunno. Uh,
yeah, I would, I would say, yeah, there's
no way he's going to fly it alone,
but I think there's a good chance that
he could, you know, flying around.
Yeah.
If, uh, if there was somebody
else up there with them,
which I would think just be
just taking the stick, you know?
Okay.
Right. I can't imagine how small
the movements are in that thing.
Before you were inverted,
you know,
terrified. It would be like, okay bill,
you have controls, I have controls,
you have controls. Right. And
then yeah, you fucking, I,
I would move that thing a fucking cunt
hair just to see because I worried that I
would be like, totally did you
want to stay in like also like
if you look at the trading of that,
okay.
But God knows he's going to do it.
Like when you've
yeah,
just, I don't even know what speed.
Anytime you, you do those maneuvers,
like they have to like tighten
up their entire fucking insides.
Are they a whole body to keep the blood
from going down to their feet and they
then passing out while they're flying?
There's this,
they have a suit at like
compresses it and like,
I mean I don't know anything about it
but like what, what they're doing is,
is just completely at like, you know, you
just look at f one racing, the amount of,
Geez,
where they're calming down
the straightaway when just
sims hitting the brakes
and then making that turn.
Like their neck muscles
are literally off the fucking chains from
just being able to hold it up. Right.
And I know they have that device in now
so they can kind of lead against it.
But back in the day, like back
in the day, those old schools,
stock car drivers like Dale Earnhardt,
if you ever went to fucking
try to choke that guy to death,
he could just sit there staring at you.
What he drank a beer is you squeezed with
all your might be like trying to choke
out a fucking Louisville slugger
and those guys who just go on,
you know, 200 miles an hour,
I can't imagine, you know.
Okay.
Is every mach speed of sound, is that what
it is? Mach one is the speed of sound.
Is that or is it a thousand miles an hour?
I can't even fucking remember.
But those plays could basically do shit
that the human body can't even fucking
handle it this point.
Um,
okay.
If it
wasn't Tom Cruise,
if it wasn't Tom Cruise,
I would be confident to say
that they won't let them do
it. But it is Tom Cruise.
It is part of his brand and that's
how it works out here. Your brand,
uh,
I'm going to say he's going to go up
with an instructor or they're going to be
flying.
Yeah.
Slow and he's gonna do some shit.
That's what I want.
That's what I'm going to guess.
He's going to learn how to
invert it and stuff like that.
And this guy's going to be, he's going
to be on with him. In other words,
he's also on the fucking controls and uh,
I dunno. I mean, Jesus quite,
you're talking about a guy that hung
onto the side of a fucking plane while it
took off, flew the pattern in
Quebec around and landed. I mean,
I wouldn't put anything past that guy.
You know,
and I get all the respect to the world
for him because all I do was memorize,
memorize my lines. It'd be like I stop
on that piece of tape and then I say it.
Okay. That's the level of
work that I put into it.
I'm kidding. I actually think of a decent
actor. All right. Then you can see it,
you know,
right now in New York and La with the
limited release of the front runner
starring Hugh Jackman.
MMM.
Who may or may not be a guest on
this podcast. Later on this week,
we shall see. We shall
see all Billy a list. Huh?
That'd be the biggest fucking
guest. Have a got, I think, uh,
be right up there with all of them. The
biggest people I've gotten to this part.
Okay. I have so few guests
that can't fucking remember.
Yeah.
Chris Leighton was a huge one drama for
Stevie Rayvon telling all those Stevie
fucking stories. That was a
big one. Uh, but anyways, the
front runner will, will be,
uh, have a nationwide release,
I believe later on this week.
And why don't you swing
by and check it out.
It's a great movie to Gary Hart's Story.
All right.
You Grant Vera Farmiga
directed by Jason Reitman. Uh,
an old freckles. Don't blink.
You'll miss me. All right.
Have a great couple of days. Go fuck
yourselves and I'll check it on Thursday.